And I want to welcome you to today's topic, which is the patients of Jung. Jung was a therapist and Jung worked a very, very long time as a therapist and he had a lot of patients and he uses them very often as examples.
And I also use them very often as examples up to one event where Chad asked me, hey, is there a sort of compendium, some kind of collection where you have all the stories because those stories are really, really interesting. They're really a lot of fun and they always show some Jungian concept, some Jungian idea very well. This is how Jung uses them.
So the idea for the event today was to really then go through a selection of those topics and stories. Yeah, have a good time. So today is more of a story time. So this is a little bit different than the normal events where I would take a specific topic and try to approach this from as many angles as possible to really make it comprehensive and clear.
Today will be about some fun, interesting, and very enlightening stories by the patients of Jung and also in Jung's own words. So when I say Jung worked as a therapist. That means he really, really worked as a therapist in really a long time. He did his medical studies, he did his PhD.
He started working with 25 in the Burghölzli, which was a mental institution for people with psychosis and schizophrenia and other mental troubles. And he would not stop working till close to the end of his life.
And this is over 50 years of therapeutic work, working with people, and he helped there hundreds and thousands of people over the course of his life directly through direct therapy.
And when you have all the works and the books and everything, there's roughly 200 stories he mentions of patients and stories that he tells from their analysis, from their background. From the things that they have experienced. And most of these stories are rather short. So what we don't have so much is really detailed case studies.
So it's, they're, let's say, not necessarily scientific to recreate the case and say, okay, this happened, that happened. It's not like a diary, it's not like a protocol, but rather he tells a story and with stories about patients that very often don't have a name.
Also, I guess for secrecy reasons, but he uses this as anecdotes and small stories to make his ideas more clear, especially in his seminars. He likes to do that to draw a comparison, and I think that's always the best way to learn something, to understand something by having examples. And especially with stories, stories are super interesting. Everybody can remember stories.
So that's a very good approach. But as I said, there's not a single place where everything is gathered. It's scattered throughout the, all the works. And we're also not gonna talk about all 200 of the stories. So I handpicked there some and went there through the books again to find interesting things.
And yeah, so this is how this should be approached to understand Jungian ideas better. And this, is also how we will do it today. And most of them are short, like of the 200 stories that Jung uses, not super, super long, except there's some exceptions.
And there are longer investigations where he really goes very often through the dreams and the creative works that a patient has created. Created. There's a seminar, it's very long, it's called Visions. It's from a seminar that ran over four years.
And there he goes through the visions a patient of his has, Christiana Morgan, and really uses this as a kind of way into his whole psychological ideas and to dreams, into individuation, into symbols and how the psyche structures and how the interactions are there within the psyche. So that's a very interesting book, very hard to get.
The last version I saw cost something like €500, but this is one of the longer case studies where her visions and her dreams are more used as a kind of way to guide through Jung's psychology. There's another very famous case, which is Wolfgang Pauli. Wolfgang Pauli is a very famous physicist.
He won a Nobel Prize for his works, and it was for particle physics. And Jung talked about him in secret. He did not mention his name when he published the work Psychology and Alchemy. That was the first book of the Collected Works that were published in English in America.
And there he just talks about, oh, there's a brilliant troubled young man who is genius in his field, but at the same time, really likes to fight people in bars and to fall in love with prostitutes and drink and gamble a lot. So he said very unbalanced and he would let him record 400 of his dreams and analyze then those. Super interesting.
And there I can highly, highly recommend the book Dream Symbols of the Individuation Process. It's a new book. It came out in the last 5 years or something like that. It's a seminar where he explicitly mentions Pauli, which makes it interesting. Before, it was a little bit more secret. Highly, highly recommended.
And then there's the story of Kristine Mann in The Archetypes and the Collective Unconscious, where he uses her paintings to show how she's developing in therapy, because Jung would let his patients draw. To express things of the unconscious. He's saying in the unconscious, in our psyche, there are things that want to express themselves. They want to come out.
And also a way how to deal with psychological problems is to bring these things out, to bring them into the world, to separate oneself from them. Before it's in the dark, it's inside. And the idea is to bring it out into the light, to objectify it, to see it then manifested. And a little bit less scary.
It's a little bit weird when you wake up in the night and you hear strange sound in your apartment or in your house and you think, oh my God, the witches are coming to get me. You of course go then there, look around and turn the light on everywhere and then see like, okay, there are no witches. It was just a broken door or the TV went on or whatever.
So psychologically that's very, very similar to that. When you have something inside of you that concerns you, it kind of needs to get out onto the light.
And of course, this is a very tough, difficult process, but Jung would do that very, very often to let his patients do something creatively, to let the thing that wants to express itself express itself, and then they can marvel at that and they can create a distance between them and a thought, a fantasy, and an emotion.
I will share the links also after the event so that you can find those books. Not all of them cost €500. The other ones are way cheaper and I can highly, highly recommend them. Interestingly enough, Jung was an analyst and he once said, mind you, every patient you have gets interested in psychology.
Inevitably, nearly everyone thinks he's meant to be an analyst. So somebody gets analyzed and thinks, oh, that's cool. Psychology is so interesting. I also want to analyze people. And a lot of people did. A lot of people that Jung treated became analysts and psychologists and therapists. He would also train people to become specifically that.
The idea that an analyst should be analyzed themselves is an idea from Jung. He proposed that he came up with that. So we have a long list of people, famous people, very accomplished people and influential people that started their career, let's say, with Jung and him analyzing them.
We got Henry Murray, who was the director of Harvard Psychological Clinic. We have Sabina Spielrein, a pioneering psychoanalyst in the beginning of psychoanalysis. We got Erich Neumann, also very famous close friend of Freud. We got Esther Harding, very popular in America.
She brought a lot of Jung's ideas into America. James Kirsch, who did his work on children's psychology, also very influential in America. Gerhard Adler, very famous psychologist. He was seen kind of on the same level as Freud and Carl Gustav Jung himself and Hans Schmid-Guisan, who was a Swiss psychotherapist.
And to have a little bit more comprehensive view, there's even a movie about one of those people and the relationship Jung had there. It is Sabina Spielrein. The movie is called A Dangerous Method. It's with Keira Knightley, Viggo Mortensen, and Michael Fassbender.
It's about the fact that Carl Gustav Jung started an intimate relationship with Sabina Spielrein after their analysis, and Jung was married at that time, which, yeah, I would just say it makes good Hollywood material, but also had their, some ramifications in the past.
So if somebody wants a really accessible way into the stories, it's a really good movie. It's a very interesting movie. We talked about it here in the meetup group before, and I can recommend it and gets also some insight into Jungian ideas.
So the, the brand of psychoanalysis and therapy that Jung practiced with his patients is called analytical psychology. It's not the same as psychoanalysis. It's a deviation from that. The dream interpretation is different. The idea of libido is different. It also has all the collective parts of the collective unconscious and so on. Freud did not have that.
That was all very personal. And here's their very different approach, and I have his two quotes to give away into that as an introduction.
He says, psychotherapy is not the simple, straightforward method people at first believed it to be, but as has gradually become clear, a kind of dialectical process, a dialogue or discussion between two persons. Because this is the groundbreaking thing that happened with Freud and with Jung and also with Adler.
It's this idea of the talking cure that you can talk with people about their problems and solve their problems that way. It's amazing. It's amazing. So groundbreaking back then, before the belief was really someone has psychological problems. That means they have damage in their brain. They are damaged goods. They need to be locked away and you just wait till they die.
There's nothing you can do. And Freud changed that and changed that, the field of psychotherapy and Jung very, very much thought in the same way. It is about talking with people and talking, expressing, getting things out is already therapeutic.
And he says, we always try to intrude with consciousness, therefore to lift out a part of the unconscious and make it a problem for people so that this process does not remain merely a natural process so that the person may benefit from it being included in the process, meaning he sees the psyche as very structured and kind of splintered in a way.
And we have our consciousness, but not everything that's happening in our psyche is available to us. A lot of stuff happens without us knowing. We might feel bad, but we don't know why. And then we find out there's something that's troubling us, but we only find that out through an investigation. Same as a lot of stuff in our body. Our heart beats without us doing anything.
Our digestion works without doing anything. And he's saying, ah, it's the same in the psyche also. There's a lot of stuff happening in the background. And he says, this can press on consciousness and this can influence a person. And that leaves them mighty scared and mighty afraid. Same as when your body suddenly starts acting up and you start to have problems in your body.
Something hurts. Right? Or you feel very, very unwell. You feel a loss of control there. In a sense, the same can happen psychologically when you have obtrusive thoughts or actions or emotions. And a way to do that is really to reestablish this contact between the conscious and the unconscious and have people participating and be more whole in their psyche.
And doing this then again through the dialectical process of talking. So I made a selection of roughly 10 stories that are interesting, that are funny, that are insightful, and they group in 3 categories. One is psychological dreams. One is synchronistic occurrences, which are always fun. Synchronicity is always fun.
And there's some lighthearted stories because all in all, you have to be a little bit careful because a lot of those stories are also depressing. Because it deals with severe topics and not every therapy is successful. But yeah, I picked out of the over 210 most interesting. Some I've mentioned before, some I did not. So it will also be a lot of new stuff.
Good. And we start with the first one, which is the Air Balloon Girl. And I will hear Carl Gustav Jung directly from his writings so that you can get a feeling for the story. I had a case, a girl of 28 who no longer heard her steps when she walked in the street. That frightened her and she came to me.
She dreamt that she was riding in a balloon, not in the basket, but on top, high up in the air. And there she saw me with a rifle shooting at her from below. I finally shot her down. She was that girl I have told you about who has never seen her body.
I suggested that she must bath once in a while, and then she told me she had been brought up in a nunnery where the nuns taught her that the sight of the body was sin, that she always should cover her bathtub with linen so that she never saw herself. I said, now go home and undress. And stand before your long mirror and look at yourself.
And when she came back, she said, it was not too bad after all. Only I think my legs are a little bit too hairy. That is the truth. That is the way people think and feel when they have such symptoms. So here we already have this idea of the disconnect.
Jung says We kind of have four ways how we process information, how stuff gets into our consciousness, and that's thinking, feeling, intuition, and sensation. And they kind of block each other out. So he says when somebody is highly, highly intuitive, they get really insightful ideas.
They kind of can predict the future and they can see things that are not there in a highly competent degree. He says those people very often have lost the access to their body, their awareness. There's things that is about their body not available to them.
And he has the stories a lot where people do not hear their footsteps, or they believe they don't have a shadow, or they walk over a bridge and they're afraid that the wind will take them away because they have no weight, they have no body. Their consciousness is not aware of their body. So establishing that is important. And here you have it.
Jung says, okay, then look at your body if you're ignoring it, if you were brought up like that. And it is about this reestablishing of a connection between consciousness and unconscious, making people aware, also making people do stuff. So it's called the talking cure, but it involves also a lot of doing. The next story is about the, a heartache story.
And he says, the case is that of an officer, 27 years of age. He was suffering from severe attacks of pain in the region of the heart. And from choking sensation in the throat, as though a lump was stuck there. He also had piercing pains in the left heel. There was nothing organically the matter with him.
The attacks had begun about 2 months previously, and the patient had been exempted from military service on account of this occasional inability to walk. Various cures had availed nothing. Close investigation into the previous history of his illness gave no clue. And he himself had no idea what the cause might be.
He gave the impression of having a cheerful, rather light-hearted nature, perhaps a bit on the tough side, as though theoretically, "You can't keep us down." As the anamnesis revealed nothing, I asked about his dreams. It had once become apparent what the cause was.
Just before the beginning of his neurosis, the girl with whom he was in love jilted him, and got engaged to another man. And talking to me, he dismissed the whole story as irrelevant. A stupid girl. If she doesn't want me, it's easy enough to get another one. A man like me isn't upset by a thing like that. That was the way he treated his disappointment and his real grief.
But now the affect came to the surface. The pains in the heart soon disappeared, and the lump in the throat vanished after a few bouts of weeping. Heartache is a poeticism, but here it became an actual fact because his pride would not allow him to suffer the pain in his soul. The lump in the throat, the so-called globus hystericus, comes, as everyone knows, from swallowed tears.
His consciousness had simply withdrawn from contents that were too painful to him, and these, left to themselves, could reach consciousness only indirectly as symptoms. All this was a rationally understandable and perfectly intelligible process, which could just as well have passed off consciously had it not been for his masculine pride.
So the idea here again is a disconnect. Someone is not dealing with something that is bothering them. In this case, a love that was not reciprocated. And it would express itself in, in the body and also in, in dreams.
And the, the interesting thing is really Jung would look at these things to find there more about the person. For example, in dreams, in this case, the patient also dreamt of a snake biting him in the foot and also like other animals biting him somewhere. The dreams are a way of the unconscious to interact with us, to talk with us, to send us images.
Very hard to understand images, very hard to understand situations, but it's a kind of reaction. The unconscious reacts to consciousness. So what is lacking in consciousness will be brought up through unconscious. This, our psyche tries to make us aware of certain problems. And the understanding is the hard part to get. The reason why this is. Why does my heart ache?
Why do I feel like I have no body? And then talking about it, letting it express itself, for example, in tears, brings up and heals the patient. But it can also have a darker turn. And the story of the mountaineer. Among many instances of this sort, there's one that has remained particularly impressive.
It concerns a colleague of mine, a man somewhat older than myself, whom I used to see from time to time and who always teased me about my dream interpretations. Well, I met him one day in the street and he called out to me, how are things going? Still interpreting dreams? By the way, I had another idiotic dream. Does that mean something to you? This is what he has dreamt.
I am climbing a high mountain over steep snow-covered slopes. I climb higher and higher, and it is marvelous weather. The higher I climb, the better I feel. I think, if I only could go on climbing like this forever. When I reach the summit, my happiness and elation are so great that I feel I could mount right up into space. And I discover that I can actually do so.
I mount upwards on empty air. And awake in sheer ecstasy. After some discussion, I said, "My dear fellow, I know you can't give up mountaineering, but let me implore you not to go alone from now on. When you go, take two guides and promise on your word of honor to follow them absolutely." "Incorrigible," he replied, laughing, and waved goodbye. I never saw him again.
Two months later, the first blow fell. When out alone, he was buried under an avalanche, but was dug out in the nick of time by a military patrol that happened to be passing. 3 Months later, the end came. He went on a climb with a younger friend, but without guides. A guide standing below saw him finally step out into the air while descending a rock face.
He fell on the head of his friend who was waiting lower down, and both were dashed into pieces far below. So Jung sees there's some ability of the unconscious to kind of predict things in the sense of it is a little bit smarter than us.
It can see, let's say, into the future in the sense of that our unconscious has a human nature, which is a distilled experience of many, many, many generations of hundreds of thousands of years. Of situations and knowledge.
We would call that today evolutionary psychology, but this deals as a kind of objective reference point. He calls that archetypes. He says we have these kind of stories in our head, these kind of rituals or things that can happen. And from time to time, these can come up, they become activated. And in the dreams, they can also point to things.
Jung would sometimes even use dreams to predict future illness that could come up, where he said, okay, yeah, there's something happening in parts of the body that the patient's not yet aware of, but the unconscious is. The unconscious kind of knows and communicates them through fantasy and through dreams.
And yeah, this is an example where Jung says the, the unconscious cannot be ignored. It's a kind of As you would have another partner living in your apartment or like an animal, like a dog living in the apartment. You cannot ignore that. You kind of have to take it into consideration. You have to build a relationship with that, and that can be very dangerous to ignore that.
Same with your health. If your stomach hurts and you ignore that, it could be cancer. It could be horrible things. So you have to take care. And it's not only that, it's more available for us for the body, but psychologically it's very much the same.
To continue on that side of strange occurrences, Carl Gustav Jung has a concept and phenomena that he explains or names synchronicity, where he says sometimes weird coincidences happen. There's stuff happening seemingly outside and inside at the same time that are related to each other, that have a meaning together.
And that seemed to be impossible because they are separated by place and by time. Uh, so all the causalities that we have, so kind of removed from logic, we would say, or some would say, but he had these stories and he would write them down and I would now go through them with you.
The first one is a very famous one and I mentioned this very often because it's a really nice story. It's called the Golden Scarab. And it's about a patient he had, a woman patient. My example concerns a young woman patient who, in spite of efforts made on both sides, proved to be psychologically inaccessible.
The difficulty lay in the fact that she always knew better about everything. Her excellent education had provided her with a weapon ideally suited for this purpose. Namely a highly polished Cartesian rationalism with an impeccably geometric idea of reality.
After several fruitless attempts to sweeten her rationalism with a somewhat more human understanding, I had to confine myself to the hope that something unexpected and irrational would turn up, something that would burst the intellectual retort into which she had sealed herself.
Well, I was sitting opposite her one day with my back to the window, listening to her flow of rhetoric. She had had an impressive dream the night before in which someone had given her a golden scarab, a costly piece of jewelry. While she was still telling me this dream, I heard something behind me gently tapping on the window.
I turned round and saw that it was a fairly large flying insect. That was knocking against the windowpane from outside in the obvious effort to get into the dark room. This seemed to me very strange. I opened the window immediately and caught the insect in the air as it flew in.
It was a scarabaeid beetle, a common rose chafer, whose golden-green color most nearly resembles that of a golden scarab. I handed the beetle to the patient with the words, Here's your scarab. This experience punctured the desired hole into the rationalism of her and broke the ice of her intellectual resistance.
The treatment could now be continued with satisfactory results. This is a very nice story. This is— I love this story. And the story is very nice because it shows something. Consciousness, our ego, what we know, how we are. As persons right now can be very fortified.
We can have incredibly strong beliefs, thoughts, emotions, and so on that can also act as walls to protect us, but also to prevent change, necessary change. We as human beings evolve and change in our psychology or over our whole life. This is what Jung really put a focus on with analytical psychology.
Because he said psychotherapy, the Freudian one, it worked for the first half of life to get people out of the basement of their parents psychologically and into the world. This very often has happened when somebody is about the midpoint of their life. So there's new things become necessary.
And it's not just that we change psychologically when we're children and teenagers and young adults and so on. He said also when we are adults, we still psychologically change. And he says there's something missing there in our cultural institutions to really take care of that.
And he says, the important thing is to understand that the ego and consciousness, it needs, constantly needs to adapt and to change. And if this does not happen, it's a kind of blockage.
And this blockage then creates problems for the patient that become depressive or have pains and can't live their life normally anymore and have weird dreams and can't do their jobs and fail in their relationships and so on. So an unblocking needs to take place. And he says the unconscious tries to well up force and strength to break down these walls.
And the stronger the walls are, the stronger this reaction will be. But at the same time, it can be incredibly scary because you might not know what's happening because your psyche acts up, your body acts up, the life around you acts up, and you don't know what's happening. But the important first step is to become open to this influence, to this change that is about.
Future you kind of is already in you, in the unconscious, and wants to come out and unfold over time like a flower. But it also needs to be let in. And that's very often means the death of the old you. So it is a death and rebirth circle that's going on there. And this needs access. And this is of course way easier when you're open to this access. To this phenomena.
And yeah, if you wait long enough, you might have beetles knocking on your window to make you open for the change. So it's interesting again, because the scarab very much associated with Egyptians who very much thought about also resurrection and traversing into another life, the afterlife. So it's a nice coincidence.
But is it a coincidence? This is a very big question. When you watch the movie A Dangerous Method, you will very often— Carl Gustav Jung will say, ah, he doesn't believe in coincidences, and he doesn't. This is why he has synchronicities. So the next story is about a fatal shooting.
The relationship between doctor and patient, especially when a transference on the part of the patient occurs, or a more or less unconscious identification of doctor and patient can lead to a parapsychological phenomena. I just want to explain very shortly. Transference is really that a relationship is built with a doctor, but it's not a professional doctor-patient relationship.
This can also be that the patient can fall in love, which is not so untypical back then or even today. And it can also have the concept of countertransference, which means the doctor falls in love with the patient. Which is not good. It's just to make clear that there is something happening in this relationship also.
So what— this is what Jung describes here, strong psychological relationship to specific patient. I have frequently run into this. One such case, which was particularly impressive, was that of a patient whom I had pulled out of a psychogenic depression. He went back home and married, but he did not care for his wife. The first time I saw her, I had an uneasy feeling.
Her husband was grateful to me, and I observed that I was a thorn in her side because of my influence over him. It frequently happens that when women who do not really love their husbands are jealous and destroy their friendships. They want the husband to belong entirely to them because they themselves do not belong to him. The kernel of all jealousy is the lack of love.
The wife's attitude placed a tremendous burden on the patient, which he was incapable of coping with. Under its pressure, he neglected to do so, particularly because of his wife, who scoffed at his moods. I heard not a word from him. At that time, I had to deliver a lecture in Berlin. I returned to my hotel around midnight.
I sat with some friends for a while after lecture, then went to bed. But I lay awake for a long time. At about 2 o'clock—I must have fallen asleep—I awoke with a start and had the feeling that someone had come into the room. I even had the impression that the door had hastily been opened. I instantly turned on the light, but there was nothing.
Someone might have mistaken the door, I thought, and I looked into the corridor, but it was still as death. Odd. I thought. Someone did come into the room. Then I tried to recall exactly what had happened, and it occurred to me that I had been awakened by a feeling of dull pain, as though something had struck my forehead and then the back of my skull.
The following day, I received a telegram saying that my patient had committed suicide. He had shot himself. Later, I learned that the bullet had come to rest in the back of the wall of his skull. This experience was a genuine synchronistic phenomenon, such as are quite often observed in connection with an archetypal situation, in this case death.
By means of relativization of time and space in the unconscious, it could be well that I had perceived something which in reality was taking place elsewhere. So these are the kind of stories that people heard about Jung. Like Jung was an incredibly open thinker.
He was open to incredibly amount of ideas, to occultism, astrology, tarot, also extra-sensical perceptions, telepathy, and so on. Because he says it's not a coincidence that people talk about these things. And he saw there things happening that are very strange, stories that happen very strange, that are very strange.
Coincidences that were very strange. And especially this case of people kind of knowing that happened, that stuff happens somewhere where they're not, is incredible. And I also have a story of that. It's when I lived back at home and I was alone at home and my parents were aware. They were on the other side of Germany, I think.
I suddenly get a call and my mother says, go in the cellar. It's overflowing with water. I say, what do you mean? You've been gone for hours. How can you know? And I said, just go down. So I went into the cellar, looked, and it was really that pipe broke and water dripped out of the washing machine.
And my father installed like a small wall so that it would not flood the whole cellar. And it was just about to overflow that wall and go into the cellar completely. And of course, I immediately turned off the water and so on. I asked her, how did you do that? How did you know? And she said, ah, I just know.
And So there is these kind of coincidences and sometimes you get like the right idea stuff before it happens or while it happens, while not being there. And Jung says, oh, that's not a coincidence. There's something happening. It's happening through our unconscious. It's happening through the collective part that there is something that is a little bit weird. We are not isolated.
We're connected there to something. And he tried to map that. And I have another of such stories about synchronicity. And it's about the Tree of Life. And it's about one of the patients who later become a therapist, Guisan, and what happened to him.
In July of the same year, Guisan, who owned a summer cabin in Jura, had a conversation with a local forest manager about which he told me in the autumn. He had a beautiful old fir tree in front of his house, in German Wettertanne. He said to the ranger that he was worried that a storm might break it one day. But the ranger said, the tree is going to get older than you, doctor.
In August, the storm broke the fir 5 meters above the ground. Guisan had the impression that when the ranger was talking with him, the tree meant his life tree. Naturally, he was struck deeply when the tree was broken. In September, he had an accident with his car. He started to glide in a corner and crashed with the side of the car into a tree.
Later that autumn, he, together with his wife, who drove, when overtaking, got caught between two cars and was squeezed. In January, he said to his wife at once, I know what you think. You think I should talk to Jung. His previous illness was remarkably and enduringly healed after he had spoken with me about his father complex. His wife said, yes, indeed.
But he didn't do anything. At the end of January, he dreamt in a wonderful heroic scenery, meeting a beautiful lady on a horse who was saddled with him. She invites him for a ride. He rides with her full joy through the magnificent landscape. They come to a beautiful country house where the lady lives. She invites him to relax on the sofa.
As he lies down, she approaches him with a whip and says, "You keep lying here and will never get up." At the beginning of March, he turned over his car. Remarkably, the other 3 passengers were unharmed. Only in his case, a tiny fragment of glass had entered his arteria radialis at the wrist.
A somewhat incompetent country doctor stitched the wound, following this, gangrene, and then finally his death. So there we have a lot of things coming together. We have dreams, we have synchronicities, and we have this kind of foreshadowing.
It's difficult what to make out of these stories. But one gets, let's say, an uneasy feeling when I think about that. I would say it's nicer to be realistic and logical and all these different things. But at the same time, these things are happening. And I think everybody knows some stories that are weird like that.
And to lighten up the mood a little bit, because I don't only want to talk about death and harm, which is a lot of stories, to be honest. I have here some stories that are just fun, and those are the, the last 4 stories, uh, for today. And the one is, the first one is about one of his first successes in psychotherapy.
So he's 25, he's very fresh, and he's practicing, and he's talking about a woman. He's talking about a middle-aged woman. Apparently with a strong religious bent, appeared one day. She was 58 years old and came on crutches, led by her maid. For 17 years she had been suffering from a painful paralysis of the left leg.
I placed her in a comfortable chair and asked her for her story. She began to tell me, and how terrible it all was. The whole long tale of her illness came with the greatest circumstantiality. Finally, I interrupted her and said, "Well now, we have no more time for so much talk.
I am now going to hypnotize you." I had scarcely said the words when she closed her eyes and fell into a profound trance. Without any hypnosis at all! I wondered at this, but I did not disturb her. She went on talking without pause and related the most remarkable dreams. Dreams that represented a fairly deep experience of the unconscious.
This, however, I did not understand until years later. At the time, I assumed she was in a kind of delirium. The situation was gradually growing rather uncomfortable, her not waking up. I became alarmed. It occurred to me that I might inadvertently have probed into a latent psychosis. It took some 10 minutes before I succeeded in waking her up.
All the time I dared not to let the students observe my nervousness. When the woman came to, she came giddy and confused. I said to her, I am the doctor and everything is all right. Whereupon she cried out, but I'm cured, threw away her crutches and was able to walk. Flushed with embarrassment, I said to the students, now you have seen what can be done with hypnosis.
In fact, I had not the slightest idea what just happened. That was one of the experiences that prompted me to abandon hypnosis at all. I could not understand what really happened, but the woman was in fact cured and departed in the best of spirits.
I asked her to let me hear from her since I counted on a relapse in 24 hours at the latest, but her pains did not recur despite of my skepticism. I had to accept the fact of a cure. I could not understand what has happened, but that woman was completely cured. She just walked away and was happy.
I begged her to tell me how things went because I assumed that after 24 hours she would have had a relapse, but the pain never returned and I just marveled at the grace of heaven. So that's a fun thing, trying to show hypnosis and not being able to wake the patient up, especially when the patient was not hypnotized. This story, I love this story.
And the next one is also from his time at Burghölzli, so in the beginning of Jung's career, and has to do with a pair of shoes. I remember a patient who was only in a relatively reasonable mood as long as I was on the premises. As soon as I took my vacation, she sank into a hole, suicidal moods, etc.
When I callously went away, as I usually do, because I know she could only get out of these holes by her own power. Even if I sacrificed myself completely, she would not get out of them. She would only get deeper into them. So he could not get her out of that, and she would just go deeper and deeper. Does not matter how much time he put into the therapy.
So I went away, and she was in despair and decided to commit suicide. She was walking down the lake to jump in, and on the way she passed a shoe store where she saw some very nice shoes and thought they might fit her. So she stepped in and bought them, and she was made all over, reborn. Her depression gone for not less than 3 weeks. She was amazed.
And when she told me what was building up a feeling of inferiority, that a pair of shoes could cure her melancholia. It put a mountain under her feet that she could not get cured. I don't know why, but the text here is like really bad. Despite all the efforts that he did, he could not help her, but the pair of shoes in the store, that could help her.
The pair of boots, uh, did the trick. It made her doubt her own internal values. I strongly advised her in case of another attack of melancholia to buy another pair. So the next time she bought something else quite foolish. Now, such experiences are not invented. From what she learned, that her melancholia was only worth about 50 francs.
Sorry, I think I botched the story there a little bit, but the idea is that really people can surprise themselves. And this is what Jung talks about very often. People are confused of the things that are happening to them. And here he says the problem was, of course, part her melancholia, But the other thing is the amount of influence that a pair of shoes had over her.
Like, her life was worth about 50 francs, which is not that tremendous amount of money. And to have this observation and this openness already and this realization to say, I behave different in other situations.
This is something that's still done in therapy today to have people, for example, and random times of the day, writing down how they feel just to get a measurement. Because when you ask a person how they feel, they will provide an overall mood, but this mood could be completely wrong for their whole life and daily.
So you kind of start to gather data points to have a counterfactual to that. And then in that fact, the counterfactual is that she's in an absolutely tremendous mood for 3 weeks when she buys a pair of shoes and say like, okay, so, so what is the problem? Like I have, I'm in, in an asylum. I am in horrible moods, but I buy a pair of shoes and everything is fine.
And this is the kind of irrationality that needs to happen. This kind of awareness, this kind of realization that there is something happening in the psyche, an influence. And this is a building ground where stuff can be started over. It's a little bit similar with the scarab. It's a realization of, oh, it is not so as I assume it to be.
And it can be very, very hard when you're in a very negative mood to see the light and see something different. But something can come in the form of a pair of shoes. And the next story is also very nice. It's about an ex-ex-alcoholic. I will tell you a story of such a case.
A hysterical alcoholic was cured by this group movement, and they used him as a sort of model and sent him all over Europe. Where he confessed so nicely and said that he had done wrong and he had gotten cured through the group movement. So a kind of religious experience.
And when he had repeated his story 20 or may it even been 50 times, he got sick of it and started to drink again. The spiritual sensation had simply faded away. Now, what are they going to do with him? And since they are moving him around showing like, oh, he was cured of his alcoholism. By the group. They say, now he is pathological, he must go see a doctor.
See, in the first stage he was cured by Jesus, in the second by a doctor. I should and did refuse such a case. I sent that man back to these people and said, if you believe that Jesus has cured this man, he will do it a second time. And if he can't do it, you don't suppose that I can do it better than Jesus? But that is just exactly what they expect.
When a man is pathological, Jesus won't help him, but the doctor will. Which is a nice story.
Interestingly enough, very few people know this, but Jung had another case of an alcoholic patient that also would relapse again and again and again, which is very typical for addicts and people with addiction behavior.
And Jung gave up at a certain point and told him, you won't stop drinking till you really had a profound religious experience. And shortly after that, that actually happened. And this patient had an experience with God, a deeply religious experience, and it cured him of his alcoholism. So he really stopped drinking.
And this man was the foundation for the organization in America called AA, Alcoholics Anonymous, where you have these 12 steps in the program to move out of an addiction, to move out of alcoholism. And the, the last step is really this acceptance of a higher power.
And here comes the crazy thing. They did research, there are studies about that. And it is absolutely clear that the success of the therapy and this intervention depends on that. People need to have a religious experience and experience of God, otherwise it does not work. And this is studied, this is very hardly understood.
And Jung was there in the beginning proposing that already. So this is again interesting. Like Jung, it's amazing where Jung everywhere pops up. He's also in the, in the lie detector. For example, the lie detector in its foundations, theoretically and scientifically, is with Jung.
He had this method called the association test where he would give people words and they would say something as a response, and he could diagnose them in their psyche what was happening, whether they had complexes or issues or other, lot of other things. And he would move forward saying, aha, the words are not even necessary.
I can measure the conductivity of the skin and get a reaction, a bodily reaction from them, which is more accurate and more precise. And this is how a lie detector works. You tell people something and you see how their skin behaves, because when people are lying, their skin becomes more moist, so it conducts electricity differently, and you can measure that.
And I read that and I thought, oh, that's absolutely amazing. So even there, Jung pops up in a lot of things. He was an influential psychologist and his influence pops up again and again at the weirdest places. And as the last story for today, this is a story that I already hinted at in the description of the event, as I called it Too Many Jesus. And let's get into that.
I often meet very religious people who identify with the old wise old man. And follow a certain principle in dealing with them. I enter upon their proposition and according to principle, whatever they want, I let them have it to the end so that finally they get sick of it.
That is the old principle of Heraclitus, who said to let the Ephesians have plenty of gold so that their viciousness would come to the daylight. Without gold, they would have to work. But if they have enough gold, They can develop their vices, and then they will become obvious. So if you have to deal with people who suffer from megalomania, just favor them until they explode.
That is the best way. If anyone is convinced that he is very good, let him believe that he is to the very edge of his existence. For if you tell him he's evil, he will make a desperate effort to be good and never get beyond his conviction of his virtue. And I always follow that principle with lunatics. Lunatics, old term.
Back then it was used, today we don't use it anymore, but I wanted to give it to you verbatim. I always follow that principle with lunatics also. Of course, with people with inflations are mild lunatics and sometimes not very mild. If a man says he is the triple God or the Pope or Jesus, I say, why not? Anyone can be Jesus.
But it happened once that I had another man in the same ward who said he was Jesus too. So we had two Jesuses. And how could I make out which one was the real one? I simply put them together in the same room and let them have it out. After half an hour, I would go in and listen to— but there was no noise.
One was standing behind the stove and the other tapping on the window, looking out. I asked one of them, now, what about the Jesus? Who is the real one? And one pointed to the other and said, of course, that is a mad ass. He saw right away that he was a madman, but he himself was mad that he could not see it. So what can you do?
Of course, you cannot cure them, but people who have inflations are not lunatics in the sense that their brain is already split and conglutinated. Into that form. So as I said, not all therapies are successful, but sometimes you just have to think unconventionally. And that's time to get like all the Jesuses you can find and put them in a room and battle it out.
Who can turn the most water into wine or cure the sick? Let's see. So to summarize the stories for today. Carl Gustav Jung sees a disconnect and missing harmony between psychological contents really as a root of psychological troubles.
And there it is important to connect the conscious, so what we know, with the unconscious, the things we don't know, because this is normally a flow that happens. We change and we move, but the problem is when we're then very fixed on a single idea, we think we're Jesus, we think we know everything, we think we're smarter. Than we actually are, this can cause great harm.
So therapy is about reestablishing this contact, and this can be completely individual how this happens. And it is individual because people are individual. As you can see, and Jung talked about this, he does not have a system. He does not follow a system. He talks as a person to another person, trying to understand them, trying to to help them develop and change.
So to have a summary for the event, it is a remarkable thing about psychotherapy.
You cannot learn any recipe by heart and then apply them more or less suitably, but you can cure only from one central point, and that consists in understanding the patient as a psychological whole and approaching him as a human being, leaving aside all theory and listening attentively to whatever they have to say. Even a thorough discussion can work wonders.
And I think this is something we all know and we intuitively do. When we have something that bothers us, that is a problem, we have to talk, we need to talk, we need someone to talk to. And the most important thing is then that the other person listens.
And this is also a great deed that we can give to other people, to listen, to let them speak, to let them formalize and stumble through their words. And through their actions and have there a lot of patience. And this is what Jung did, and this is how he saw patients should be treated. And yeah, it's a very, let's say, positive outlook.
And this is what makes Jung interesting. So if you found these stories and the things I talked about interesting, as I said before, I have a podcast. I already did a lot of things. There is a history of similar topics. For example, when you're interested in therapy and more about analytical psychology, there's episode 26.
It's called Analytical Psychology and Therapy, fittingly, where I go deeper into that. Then there's one about this isolation. It's called On Secrets. It's episode 38. It deals with this. Concept that very often people withdraw when they have problems. They withdraw, which is a very dangerous thing because then you're kind of trapped in your own limitations.
So we need other people. We don't only exist in ourselves. We exist in the relationship that we have with other people. People bring stuff out in us that we do not have access to ourselves. And family relationships are very interesting and they have a very big influence on our psyche and our relationships.
So there's episode 8 called Mother Father Child, which I can also highly recommend. And yeah, this is to further deep dive through the work of the Jung Helpdesk, but of course I also recommend the books.